Is the most wonderful time of the year.
Again,
the 12,019 the human error calendar is out.
Go Get our new limited edition now all regret it forever.
We heard your comments on last year's edition,
so we've updated the design.
Each illustration is now featured on a full page with so much more space to take
notes below.
Exactly 2.36689 times as much as in the old layout.
Also,
the calendar has a spiral binding shiny silver letters on the cover and is
printed on a hike or dizzy paper.
That's nice to touch.
The calendar looks awesome on your wall,
but it's also the easiest way to tick off your whole present list for Christmas.
If you order now,
it would arrive before the holidays and it's the perfect gift for your friend's
kids.
Grandma Doggo,
mortal enemies,
all random strangers you meet on the street on the inside you find 12 brand new
beautiful illustrations of early human cultures and craftsmanship prior to the
first civilizations and the use of metal.
This topic is endlessly fascinating to us.
Our ancestors achievements from 10,000 years ago paved the way for our modern
civilization,
so we can only dream of what might be possible in the future through human
cooperation.
By the way,
if you're wondering about the date we explained why 12,019 should be our current
year in our a new calendar for she managed the video audio calendar.
Now it will be available as a limited edition until our stock is sold out and
then never again.
Please shoot when Canada is a super fun side project we got to do for the third
time.
Thanks to your support.
We loved getting mails,
tweets,
and pictures with your calendars from over 80 countries last year.
So we're already looking forward to all your messages
right.